cool okay so I think you started a
little late so we'll try to cut my talk
a few minutes shorter but I might still
need to go few minutes into coffee break
um so yeah so basically i will talk
about the exact same exciting topic
except i will make my life a whole lot
easier by not trying to prove lower
bounds on communication which this is
incredibly hard instead I will prove i
will just basically provide coding
schemes all right so i will show that we
can actually achieve pretty good
capacity and to answer your question I
think so I I think we have to write
answers from the upper bound side so I
think we know exactly what see what the
capacity is was for the adversarial case
and the random case yeah proving that
this is actually is writing most of the
work is done actually most of the
machinery we should just work but yes
there's a little little last step is
it's not yet okay let me first maybe
quickly connect it back to kind of
sanitation and the pictures that i had
had used yesterday just to refresh the
memory so we want to do error correction
442 party interactive communication
right so this Alice pop-up say go was a
talk back and forth and compute
something and now we want to consider
the case that there's some fraction of
errors here and for today we want four
for this talk we want to think of see
errors to be reasonably small okay so
last time we looked at kind of what is
the maximum amount of errors that we can
tolerate of course if you go to the
limits and the communication needs to
blow up a lot the big question is all of
C protocols that we saw last time even
if the error is small even if C amount
of noise goes to zero the blow-up is
still use some constant factor thousand
ten thousand I don't know so even if
it's just a single error or
you know like a handful of areas that we
want to tolerate we still need to
essentially repeat everything a hundred
thousand times more off and what we want
to see today is that you know in error
correction code you know exactly housing
scale right so if the noise goes to 0
then the overhead goes to zero and
something like this would be really cool
right so this is part 2 let's think
about small error I mean small dish
error let's say for example one percent
of the whole communication gets
corrupted and be in this talk again I
will just talk about I will talk about
the harder case so at the sale errors
right any temper any one percent of this
conversation can get corrupted and we
still want to be able to do this instead
of talking and symbols we want to talk
alpha n bounce and we want this alpha to
be small right so in the error
correcting code case if the
communication only goes in one direction
then alpha is how large independence on
epsilon for small epsilon
so if i want to send n symbols over a
channel with a noise rate of epsilon how
many symbols we actually need to send
over yes so or kind of the blow-up fact
there will be something of 1 plus age of
epsilon and in the adversarial case
we'll be talking about co distance we
don't know exactly what this constant is
it somewhere between one and two and we
don't need speak open question to know
what's the consonants or in this talk we
will not care we will not be able to
determine second order constants so this
is what we have in the in the case and
now eschar nobody said this does not
like this the same trade so this goes to
one is epsilon goes to zero that's great
we cannot achieve the exact same trade
off or similar trade-off in the
interactive case so let me just kind of
go over what is the things that we know
so so basic yeah so what we know is for
Brenda or yeah but we can prove them
from kind of phones the coding scheme
side it said for venom errors or
oblivious or computationally bounded I
mean anything that that we can make
oblivious like a computationally bounded
adversary for example if you have shared
hidden randomness see capacity will
behave as 1 minus square root of epsilon
if you can prove that this is tied it's
a conjecture in the adversarial case it
will be 1 minus square root of epson
block lock 1 over epsilon since we can
prove that this is I conjectures assist
act like the square root of log log
whenever epsilon factories is needed and
there's a little bit of an annoying
thing going on this I service with the
whole communication order thing so let
me just spend a minute to try to clarify
what's what's the problem is usually in
so far we've only looked at alternating
protocols why because it was essentially
without loss of generality it can take
in general protocol busy a communication
orders whatever we want and just Pat it
to make it alternating and that loses as
a factor of 2 and the rate makes
protocol at most effective to longer so
for we didn't care about rate you know
that's perfectly fine it's without loss
of generality if you care about rate
then then this reduction of kind of just
like if you want to talk twice let me
say nothing in between that we can't do
anymore right so now we need to
distinguish can we do we have an
alternating protocol or do we have a
general approach and basically I see you
should really just stick with an
alternating protocol sin life then you
just need non-adaptive protocols life is
simple and clean or if you want to
simulate general protocols and you want
to talk about rate it's possible you can
do it if if you allow it up oh did I
mess this up um if you allow oh yeah M
yes so wait there is alternating there's
fixed order but not necessarily
alternating and then there's anything
goes so so the input doesn't need to
adapt there's no noise to adapt to so
there's no notion of like you see input
adapter for not adapters the input is
has a fixed communication order and I
said alternating or it's whatever you
want there's nobody like what would you
adapt to the original protocols in the
noiseless settings there's nothing to
adapt to all right so for the input
protocol we can either say it's it's
alternating oh it's an arbitrary
communication player said some bead and
then depending what what bits and it's a
second pair may have different orders
sure sure that set is still called it
fixed communication order it's very
clear from the transcript at any point
of time both parties know who should
speak next is going to be no confusion
because we're what's the confusion come
from no but when you are then
trying to get errors yeah so when you in
the simulation we can talk about
adaptive or non-adaptive and all I'm
saying is it if you have an al tonight a
nice protocol to start this so it's
alternating you can simulate it non
adaptively and gets a perfect rate if
you have a general protocol then either
you do it non adaptively or actually you
cannot even get you cannot hope to get
close to a constant anyway I keep this
up let's let's let's let's keep this
offline right just just think of the
protocols being being alternating and
don't be confused by the fact that
you're proving you know like lower bound
send the impossibility results because
they're kind of indifferent different
quadrants here ok cool so yeah so these
weights are so getting the right way
it's just cool but the reason why I
really likes the things that i want to
show you it's not just because they
achieve the right weights but because
they're dead simple right so the
protocols that we had here if you want
some computationally efficient you need
to start with it there's a tree code
brute forces and the one of sparta calls
and boost it then do the reduction and
you know it's not it's not particularly
simple what i will show you is super
simple you can explain it to your mom no
really and it's gonna be like five line
algorithm okay more or less um so so
here's see here's the idea if you want
to what's the problem if we won the
protocol without any coding so at some
point errors happened we might
misunderstand each other it might walk
down the hole completely useless pass in
the protocol so here's a simple idea of
doing coding for interactive
communication runs the protocol is if
there's no noise half your conversation
do no coding just half your conversation
as if there's no noise and every now and
then check whether you're still on the
same page
if you're not on the same page try to
backtrack to a stage very very it's the
same stage if you seem to be on the same
same page continue mix makes plenty of
sense right I remember that's probably
more or less how we have conversations
not likely we add like a lot of
redundancy to it now we just have the
conversation if at some point we
realized that there's something fishy
you know we find a final step wave you
still agreed okay so now that seems like
a very fluffy big idea so let's actually
write this down as a concrete algorithm
okay and it will give you completely
formal algorithm would be reproof it
there's one simplifications that ever
make it will assumes that the alphabet
over which we work so you have a bed
size of the input and the alphabet size
of sea of the simulation is a
logarithmic so instead of communicating
bit by bit be communicating over verbs
okay sent you log in bits using me log
in bits the ideas that it makes
everything much cleaner okay so it's a
simple coding scheme
and yeah so as I said log of Sigma is
now that sits at the only simplification
now let's write down more formally what
I said we repeat a bunch of times we do
this for me pick some block lengths be
ok think of b b is going to be like
something like 1 over square root of
epsilon it's smaller than the noise so
it's the noise this one percent yes and
each such a bit is this or is it
simulating because the same off of it
actually we kind of have to use the same
alphabet Baku Perkins we cannot because
so that's also about anything with three
chords is kind of problematic because we
cannot hope to reduce the number of
rounds and if you use the larger
alphabets and that's already kill us in
the in the right right so we really so
think of yeah so see the final result
will work of a binary alphabets if you
want to but here we making our life easy
and be workable arch other words it's
the exact same alphabet and it kind of
has to be
okay so we have a block length and that
block length is larger than one it's
chosen in such a waste if we cannot have
kind of one error in every block right
so if the error rate is one percent then
we can have an error in every hundred
blocks in every hundred steps and we
choose B to B squared off sat so like 10
10 blocks wide so we operate so we have
n over B plus a little bit of extra
number of iterations in each iterations
we continue our conversation continue
our original protocol pb4 be steps and
think of kind of you keep track in our
head watch the conversation is so far as
we keep a transcript keep some
transcript t ok now after we have
communicated for a bunch of steps we
want to check with v on the same page
what do we use to check whether be on
the same page caching right so we do the
usual saying we sample independently
venom some seat so let's say I describes
this for Alice Alice samples login side
seat and it sends over she sends over
the seat and it's a hash transcript
right so she hashes the whole transcript
age according to the hash functions it
belongs to the seat let's call the edge
of a and we sent this over and popped us
the same thing so we receive kind of the
same kind of transmission from from pop
right receive pop we receive pop seat
and we receive spots pops hash and I
bright Prime's here because these things
might get corrupted so we're not sure if
you
we received right saying why not and
okay now what should we do we should
check whether we on the same page what
does it mean to be on the same page if
so what are we checking yes I agree so
what what do i compute see ya so I take
the hash function according to the seats
that I've received from from Bob I apply
to my own transcript and hopefully if no
errors happened whatsoever then this
should be the same as what Bob computed
on his side if this is the case we're
very happy this is it's not the case
something went wrong and we should
prepare should go back a bit right so
what do exactly do we mean let's go back
um well first of all most likely see
errors happened in these last be steps
so let's just remove source from the
transcript way okay it could be that sa
ridiculous p prime oh um if Seyi em if
they're not if they equal might be is
that there were many errors and we were
unlucky not catching them it might be as
it's ever errors in here and the
transcript was also corrupted I mean you
have an adversary right cfsa could have
co-opted the hashes to make a sink
severe that everything is in order even
though it's not all of these things can
happen but at least yeah I think it will
prove that this works so we remove p
steps from the last p steps from from t
from the transcript and just removing
the last steps for exactly the reasons
that he said cannot work because it
might be said an error happened above
the adversary did not let make it make
us catch it in this round and then we
continue further the error is going to
stay there if you never go back if you
only removes the last few steps and then
compute new one remove some compute blue
one remove sim will never work right so
it's very least
let's go another be steps back another
block back remove the last nice block
and remove extra ok and this algorithm
almost works this one place where it it
doesn't break which is feel easily drawn
so the problem is once we get out of
sync you might never really get back
into sync so what can definitely happen
is that you have a conversation you walk
down the tree then at some point I
continue because for me as a hash looks
fine or we diverge let's say one party
starts backtracking the other party
still starts going down alright so this
can definitely happen so we end up with
something axes now if you start if no
errors happen now anymore at all we
would realize that an error happens we
go both back two steps yes errors
happened we go back here now you're on
the same pass but a different depth
still the transcripts don't match if you
now backtrack both two steps you don't
get any closer right we walk back tried
two steps and chase each other all the
way to the beginning so that's kind of
stupid so let's avoid this how do you
avoid this who should backtrack here
what is the deepest one right so how do
we modify the thing to to to avoid this
problem to the hood epr so instead of
just sending they say hash we also sends
the links and let's say yes sir lengths
of the transcript and we receive all
thanks or something that's supposed to
be a length and here instead of having
both people goals as you see extra back
step we only go back if you use a deeper
one if you're supposedly is a deeper
here if if the transcripts one match we
definitely don't keep the last v-steps
but if you use a deeper ones and eagle
an extra be backtracking extra step so
if what my length is larger or equal to
the reported length of but then i close
x or accept ok now this works this is
the whole protocol and it works for
adversaries yes yes so let's let's prove
said that actually I mean says they're
very reasonable concerns right because
now we kind of trusting that you do the
right thing so this works this is the
whole thing and we can prove it properly
just on the sport yes will you get here
is randomized if if the noise is also
randomized can you fix the roundness
here together to jam 216 m z is um
I don't know and need to think about it
so or I don't know that's yeah with
random guys can't be can we actually
just use an error correcting code at
each step that if it's a polynomial size
um yeah so if right if well not it's not
really in the sense that like
corruptions here still over the whole
alphabet right i mean like the adversary
gets to replace a whole symbol by a
completely different symbol and that
counts as one error so error correcting
codes would still not solve something
large alphabet is just for illustration
right this actually works for by this
will work yeah I mean it becomes much
cleaner there's a large alphabet this
conveys all the ideas without sedan v I
talked about it hopefully Wow and let's
let's press proof that this works ok
before you could you just go through the
last two years yes so we take the seat
from the that we received from the other
party we use the same hash function if
the seed was received correctly and
rehash our transcript and we checked
whether we get the same outcome as the
other side if the seat is correct and
and everything then this should an
invierno error so far than this should
match if it doesn't match then something
went wrong so we definitely do not at
you know we remove the last three steps
that we communicated in cases there was
an error or high up we also want to go
back you don't want both priorities to
go back the same amount of steps because
it's changed chasing issue so we asked
each party to also report the lengths of
the transcript and only half the deeper
one public it's purportedly you know
like all of this that's why their primes
during the last four lines as well both
both are both independently on their
side the same protocol for possum they
just on yeah I you corrupt the value of
T then they could both think that
they're absolutely absolutely yeah and
and against an adversarial error it's
it's totally possible that we diverge by
n over epsilon many rounds right say n
over epsilon errors that can be applied
the adversary can apply them all to the
beginning of the protocol and completely
fake us out the first epsilon fraction
of the protocol might be completely made
up the divergence can be as large as
anywhere epsilon is completely
unavoidable but then it has used up all
its error you will realize it we will
backtrack and then walk down in this
case it works and we want to say that
this works injure the adversary doesn't
know the the seeds that will be using
you know the adversary doesn't know the
future so I'm trying to understand why
you
you know the move and X from these steps
and you don't try to synchronize at that
point oh the for example what we could
do is well we already get a reported
length right if the other priority says
there was an error we know that there
was an error and it says hey I'm it's a
step why don't I jump to this step the
reason why you don't want to do this is
because this lengths might be completely
made up so the adversary could just miss
a single corruption could say hey look
there was an error and hey i'm at the
very beginning of the protocol if you
take that for face value and you you
know jump to the beginning of the
protocol if it's just one error I've
killed all the progress you've made so
that's why you don't want to do this so
that already let's let that already kind
of goes into the right direction right
so review what we want to say so now
it's a steps that we make our only local
yes the FSA can make us go into the
wrong direction in an arbitrary bad way
build a never step very far right and
because the block length is small the
episode can only corrupt one tenth of
the block so it can't make a step in the
wrong direction two of them it came for
a while but overall it cannot make a
step in the wrong direction call and and
that's why this works so let's actually
let's prove set this work so the way we
prove this is just by using some kind of
potential right be saying that CF is the
adversary invest errors it can make us
go in the wrong direction and decrease
our potential but if it doesn't send we
make profits so if you just look a
conversation kind of our situation right
now is we are consistent up to some
point and then at some point we diverge
we might be a different different deaths
we don't know and we want to assign to
this a potential
what what would be a good potential to
assign to this situation how much
progress have you made so let's call the
number of links that we agree l+ and how
much noise we waste it we could puts us
into end into the potential we also kind
of have to look at how much we disagree
right because we you have to work to
make this go away so so let's call
whatever the length of said we disagree
let's call this minus and simple
potential at plus minus or minus okay so
now let's let's prove that good things
happen to this potential so lemma 1 and
if you have no error and no hash
coalition like you could also have I
mean there's this will happen very
unlikely we can essentially treat hash
collision as if they were errors because
they don't happen too often so if you
just cause some errors and so if you
have no error or no hash collision then
the potential goes up by at least one
that's a claim and that's just saying
that our algorithm doesn't do any I mean
if you don't need to fear with it it
does the right thing so why why is this
a case well it's basically only two
things I so you are at the same point in
this case we will compute the next V
step all the hashes we'll bill match
because there are no errors and we will
have added one block oh yeah let's count
this in number of blocks right we've
added one block to our our links l plus
increase by 1 minus is still 0
everything is good on the other end if
you somehow on different pages if you
walk down we will realize the view on
different pages we will remove for the
walk down and then the deeper one of us
or both of us will backtrack at least
one step so this will decrease a minus
and keep our plus the same so again kind
of put
increases by one so now we need to show
that no matter what the adversary does
it can't make us go to bed right and
basically any iteration no matter how
much how how badly and how weird and how
many errors the adversary invests in one
iteration it cannot make our potential
go down by more than a constant any
iteration increases I by at most sweet
so say it's clear that there are some
constant because we only you know I mean
the only goes steps in one direction not
that it's three and not for it to won't
really make a big difference you can
just go through all the cases the bet is
the worst case where how you can
actually get three is let's say if he at
the same spot when you perfectly agree
but now the adversary makes me go back
and you go forward now L plus decreased
by one and then minus went from zero to
two so this is how it is a potential
decrease by mystery these steps that
counts as a comp yeah so let's call it
counts in number of blocks yeah okay and
this is it I mean this is basically
proves correctness I mean now we just
need to count right so and indices that
we ran for four not for enough runs so
how do we prove correctness rightness
let's look at the final potential final
potential the final potential basically
in each round we make by default we make
more progress one so how many how many
iterations to be half n over B plus 8
times and epsilon in every round and
Cynthia been a venir was introduced our
hash collision was introduced oui oui
instead of going 14 booty goes three
backgrounds
alright so we need to subtract four
times now how many ears can happen in
total this protocol will never run more
than two times n rounds I mean we want
to achieve good weight will actually
achieve 1 plus epsilon but definitely
not longer than two times M you get an
epsilon fraction of errors and I don't
know why what is a small i thought i had
to do right by something this is the
number of france where we can get get an
error well this 8th with conveniently
chose this cancels out so this is at
least n over B which means at the very
end V agree on and what we blocks which
means we agree on what we want this post
correctness and now the last things that
we want to check is that this is fast
all rights this achieves a good rates at
the Alpha a blow-up set we have this is
what we want it to be so now what see
what's the time we have so big n the
number of rounds at even is the number
of blocks so n over B plus some constant
times n epsilon in each iteration is how
long well it's P rounds long plus a
constant number of France vs
b + 2 in this case but let's not care
what's constant B plus water one as we
multiply this out this as n times 1 plus
some constant and then their two terms
one is an nol 1 over B term and one is
an epsilon Peter now we want this to be
as small as possible how do we choose B
we can choose how do we choose B to make
this work out what makes them to equal
and then B becomes kind of 1 over square
root of epsilon right so which is
exactly I mean you know I told you to
begin with but but this is reason why we
choose it to be one of us a square 1
over square epsilon right so this
becomes 1 plus square root of epsilon
and this is I mean this trade-off is
very intuitive so you're losing weight
in two ways you're losing weight by
adding these basically constant number
of things every be blocks even if no
error happens you lose the 1 over B
wages by adding that redundancy if you
make block lengths too small you lose
too much weight you're checking too
often on the other hand whenever this is
an error you need to backtrack at least
the whole block the whole block of
precincts gets lost and this whole
potential analysis shows that in an
amateur I sense it's not more than a
constant times constant number of blocks
at giggles right so for every error
epsilon fraction of some we lose a be
because of sabacc tracking now you want
to balance between and this is all so
this is basically the same underlying
principle in the lower bound actually
one of the one of the tweeny too there
should be some dependence on the
probability of failure no this is a
adversarial case you always succeed like
if all the seeds were zero oh yeah so
what we used here said the probabilities
that you have a failure is I means you
can basically treat hash collisions as
errors because the fraction of hash
collisions has very very high
probability
where you know it's if you're tolerating
epsilon errors somewhere they should
also be a term that depends in the
probability of failure the protocol not
always sexy it will succeed with was
high probability right exponentially
high 22 ZM actually I think enthusiam
nobody answer that one minus n to the
minus n but what a hash function or
first that you're using though the
alphabets of the polynomial size
alphabet size yeah so yeah yeah so let
but we need to be need more than epsilon
fraction of the times the thing to fail
to to to to lose so that's really unpack
um no judgment here but I don't think my
mom could understand no this part is
this right not but said you just have
the conversation and you backtrack if
you misunderstand each other is that
part maybe the other companies is not
quite clear when they never said when
they accepted the universe our oh no you
fix the number of France that you run
like I mean be banned for this many runs
errors in the last rounds or something
like how do you work how do they what is
the final output yeah so actually what
can happen here is that I say you know
runs this protocol for this many rounds
but the protocol is really only n blog I
mean n over B blocks long so what do you
do if you come to the end of the
protocol and I say continues the
conversation just send zeros just take
the original protocol and attach like a
long string of zeros to each leaf David
comment because then you're kind of
relying on just one hash again what if
the air is at the very you know so what
you will happen is it if no errors
happen in the very beginning you go to a
leaf and you will run deep down on the
past basically all the 0 say yes this is
the right answer yes this is the right
answer and then it's the last stop fails
you will remove one of these
confirmations but you will still be very
deep in this leaf
so do you wait for a certain number of
confirmations is that no you just run
for this mini round for a fixed number
of rounds and you look it but what leaf
you end up it runs for you if you fix
the number of rounds to begin with if
you tell me is the error rate is one
percent i tell you and NGC protocols
that you want to simulate as hundred
runs long I tell you I need one plus ten
percent of 100 rounds to do it I will
run it for exactly this mini bounds
that's because if I don't fix the
lengths it's not clear how much budget
well you see adversary at the end you
don't have to be on the same way right
no you will I mean this proof said you
will be X correctly for things you added
if there are problems there that your
backpack but we may be different plays
around the original protocol will be a
prefix of both answers that's a
guarantee yeah so you these are just
zeros so you might end up here and I'm
and end up here but you know bebos will
say this is the right answer so yeah so
I think this is pretty much this is
pretty much it so these the only thing
that doesn't work here I mean the only
thing that said we made our life easeus
it's the lock inside suffered and I
think this is also like it's if you try
to go to a constant alphabets and I say
at least three reason why it really
looks almost impossible to bring this
into the constants I self of it which is
this part here we use one symbol right
it was a constant number of symbols to
do the checking and here we have log in
bits very convenient but if you're going
over constants as alphabet we can only
use a constant number of symbols for
this checking procedure if it's more
than a constants and each block will
have even base random errors will get
corrupted and never get anything now the
seedlings so we need to hash in the FSL
case transcripts that are at least order
in long because it the divergence can be
order n epsilon naught if you want to
hash strengths of order n he knows that
you need log and bits of randomness
it's at least in one shot you need login
bits of randomness oh that seems kind of
hard to how hard would you hash an order
and long string there's a constant
number of bits of randomness same thing
we need to say hash output to be to be
if you have a constant fire just a
constant here then we have a constant
probabilities that I hash fails
independent of epsilon then we have why
don't we have too many hash collisions
and the other thing is the length if you
cannot determine who is deeper how can
we coordinate how can we get back in
sync but the diversions can be ordered
in long how can you get possibly
coordinate whose depot is not this out
sending at least log and bits of of
information all right so that I think
it's also the only reasons like this is
so simple and people have tried stuff
like this before these are the only
reasons why this is not the first thing
that was ever done and this is the end
of the stories this is why you know me
included say like tons of other papers
that are much more complicated but all
of these three problems can be dealt
with and now it makes sense to ask for
each other six invasion sure but I mean
you can get this non uniformly
deterministic if you don't care what
wait this is also very similar to
practice [ __ ] live for example I mean
this is more or less brackets [ __ ] lie
except they can't do things uncoded to
need to because they need to be of large
logarithmic sizes they need to kind of
an energy to need to use three chords
here and everything becomes more
complicated and you don't get right and
so on right i mean g the general idea of
backtracking the something went wrong
that is nothing that i came up this
right I agree but I think it's
interesting to define a deterministic
simulation that achieve the same yes
yeah
um okay yeah so yeah I thought I don't
have time to to tell you how to actually
get around these problems but I sweets
paper or talk to me or yeah